it's been nearly three years since one
of the most powerful blasts killed
dozens and destroyed neighborhoods in
the Lebanese Capital the investigation
into what caused the explosion has
repeatedly been stalled by political
pressure
but a surprise decision by the lead
judicial investigator bitar has given
back hope to the victims families we are
surprised by the decision this decision
at the same time we are happy because
it's not normal from
more than one year the investigation is
blocked now we have a little of hope
that somebody something is moving on the
lead judge has released a number of
detainees and charged new officials and
set dates for questioning in February
among them heads of security bodies like
major general Abbas Ibrahim and
high-ranking judges including the
prosecutor General Hassan awadat it's a
first in a country with a history of
impunity but all indications point to
the fact that the political and security
establishment won't cooperate the public
prosecution's response was Swift it
rejected the implementation of bitar's
release and prosecution orders
we're seeing once again the political
establishment uh
thing to
to the case of the very blast we haven't
really seen government officials of the
judicial officials engage in any serious
manner with the legal arguments that
Bhutan has made effectively uh saying
blocking the continuation of the
investigation and blocking Justice a
political campaign against bitar has
been led by the group Hezbollah who
accuses him of bias the judge has sought
to question many of its allies including
a former prime minister Hassan dieb who
has been charged with homicide with
probable intent the decision to resume
the investigation has started a legal
debate there was no court order but
judge Batar reinstated himself basing it
on legal justifications he argued a
Judicial investigator cannot be
dismissed or removed and that his task
ends once he issues an indictment in the
case
families of victims haven't stopped
their Quest For answers and Justice they
want to know who brought the ammonium
nitrate to Lebanon and who unsafely
stored it at the Port it may be a long
way for that battle to be won but the
resumption of the probe has already
reignited tensions